domain in restrictions domain and
restrictions are two ways of two
opposite ways of looking the same idea
right domain is one days of X will work
in this given functional relation and
restrictions are which ones don't work
okay that make sense so when you first
meet functions right we have no need to
think about this idea about domain or
restrictions because the first kinds of
functions that you meet don't have any
domain for restriction problems right
like y equals x plus 3 you're like I can
just put in any numbers that I like and
I'm just going to get values why would
there ever be a problem okay but it
doesn't take very long to encounter
functions that do have issues with like
you can't just throw it in any value
that you like into X right what's the
first one that you meet think about it
it says I just need a domains by the way
just thinking about exes because they're
more they're more interesting in the
rain just kind of comes from that I kind
of suggests very very early on even
though you don't have this language the
first one you meet is this guy right
because you meet the square root of x as
soon as you start doing Pythagoras right
now you haven't thought about functions
and all that kind of thing but you know
everyone once they get the calculator
they work out what square root does
everyone tries to put in a negative
underneath and it's like oh did it does
it work now all it means is there's no
real value that corresponds to there is
a value that does but we're talking
about real functions aren't which so in
real functions there's a domain
restriction okay what's the domain
restriction on this
X is greater than or equal to 0 I can
take the square root of zero and it's
still a real number zero okay now
there's a restriction then you keep
going through all the different kinds of
graphs that you learn and you meet other
ones right well it might be the next one
that you meet I'd say one an X the
hyperbola right this guy's a problem but
it's not so much of a problem right
there's only one value one value that
breaks this guy namely x is equal so
therefore i was saying this or this
right everywhere except for zero okay
now so far there's one of the main
category of function that we've met that
also has this problem of you can't just
put in any value like we made quite
recently what is it it's these guys
right logs if I say log base any
constant of X right where can this
exists where could this experience good
it's x is greater than zero not
inclusive of the boundary not in
question okay and these are basically
yet like these your main categories okay
so for instance if you see something
like this which is actually one of your
one of your questions how do you
approach this thing how do you purchased
it now this is a combination of these
two guys so you need to keep them both
in mind okay the first thing I would say
is let's just think about the square
root let's just think about the square
root because before i get to the
fraction i have the square root first so
what I need is that what's underneath
the square root which is two minus X
that must be greater than or equal to 0
does that make sense right so that's
just to take care of the square root so
what you're getting here is if you move
that ligature over and then you divide
that's what you get are you happy with
that so there's a restriction according
to the square root yeah
okay so one step at a time I've dealt
with it square root but then I also need
to notice into fraction so not only can
this thing you know not me it's got a
less there I can't even actually include
the battery value either write X can't
equal to because what she put that in
your dividing by 0 this other kind of
thing comes in right so therefore x is
less than 2 only okay so really in terms
of restrictions as are these there's
only three categories you need to worry
about and sometimes it's a little
complicated when you throw in more than
one if we really want it to be not very
nice we can go log base 2 who you know
but it's actually not that bad because
it's actually quite like they all fit
together in a similar way um but these
are the kinds of things you're going to
meet and how their combined okay you can
think about it purely algebraically if
you like just keep in mind these guys
which hopefully as your graph will get
into your brain